all right so we're going to start today
with something a little different we'll
we'll be kind of taking a tour or having
a lesson in um reactionary
fear-mongering and how
uh people can get sort of sucked into
reactionary thinking and these
reactionary ideas and we're going to
start today we actually have two clips
that we're going to look at two
different segments in the first clip
we're going to look at a piece of an
interview that right wing host glenn
beck recently did with a guy named james
lindsey
and
i don't want to say too much about the
clip to start with other than
you really
can identify
serious analogies to the sort of
febrile screeds of authoritarians and
fascists over the history of the 20th
century there's a lot of
mussolini in what i'm going to play for
you here and what you were going to see
are essentially
unfounded conspiracy theories presented
in a particular way
to make you afraid
and to make you want to say we have to
stop this and the way to stop this
is by
discriminating against others taking
away the rights of others etc and you're
going to see glenn beck conducting the
interview here james lindsay is being
interviewed and let's just jump right in
and then we're going to talk about a lot
of different things here they they know
that i have this really bizarre belief
not to get too theoretical out of that i
don't believe that we ever actually had
a marketplace of ideas i don't think it
actually arrived i think we ended up
getting an aristocracy of ideas through
these expert class whether it's i agree
big government whether it's you know uh
progressive era yeah i think the first
part here is
even the information you are given it's
all controlled by elites individuals and
it's not true and they want to apply
this to covid right now but they want to
apply it to a lot of other things and of
course there's always a kernel of truth
which is well we should all
think about how we came to believe the
things we believe we should think
critically but these are the very people
who write off that type of education
critical thinking epistemology
philosophy media literacy as left-wing
indoctrination so they're telling you
you've been tricked but they also don't
want you to have the tools to avoid
being tricked i had an aristocracy of
ideas and what happened is that the
internet has unleashed
the flame of the enlightenment a second
time and and of course again
he's right that the internet has made it
difficult for people to figure out
what's real and what's not but the
disinformation that is being spread on
the internet
in the covet era is disproportionately
right-wing nonsense there's also
left-wing nonsense on the internet as
well and we've talked about you know
natural news and anti-vaxx movements
that pre-date kovid which which did have
elements on the left but they're they're
describing what they've done
i'm telling you these people are frauds
and they're criminals and they're
they're jokes and it it's
it's coming for them they are going to
lose all of their power they're going to
be exposed for crimes
the likes of which we've never seen in
human history
you you are 100 right this is
this i believe is the biggest crime in
all of human history and of course what
are they talking about right they are
stimulating fear it's not even really
clear like what are you saying is the
crime that people post stuff to the
internet that we don't think is true
like what exactly are you talking about
and this is typical they use grandiose
language trump does it too it's the it's
the biggest political crime we've ever
seen and it's not super clear what it is
but you see them being alarmist and it
makes others alarmist five of the
biggest crimes in human history mix into
one yeah and it when it when it
when it all hits
if they don't have us all in cages right
um they're in trouble they're in a lot
of trouble
now that's again it's it's going to get
much worse and they might enslave us and
on and out but but what are they even
talking about trouble and if they do
have us all in cages
we're in a lot of trouble because
the you know i saw this i don't know if
you saw this clip from the world
economic forum one of the elite said you
know we did this uh study
and uh the good news is the elites
trust the other elites more than ever
before
but
the others don't trust us anywhere on
earth
you better have a
rock-solid prison
everywhere yeah because
there will be a revolution yeah what on
earth is he talking about and i really
want to encourage everybody
to read the article the reactionary trap
by seth moskowitz we're going to have
seth on the show in maybe in april to
talk about it
he outlines just google
seth moscow it's the reactionary trap
we're also going to link to it on the
youtube channel
he explains exactly
how people fall into this reactionary
type thinking and he specifically talks
about james lindsey in the article
actually actually and when we say
reactionary what we're talking about is
someone with extreme opposition to
dramatic social or political change
and of course sometimes there's reasons
to oppose dramatic social or political
change
but what distinguishes reactionaries as
seth writes in the article is number one
they become so preoccupied with who or
what they are against
that the foundation of their own
politics throws out all reason and first
principles and we've seen this now for
years and as i've told you before you
have these right wingers who state
certain principles and as soon as the
principles conflict with what the
outcomes are or are inconvenient to the
outcomes they want they abandoned their
principles we've seen this when it comes
to business regulation we've seen this
with my body my choice all these
different things they have principles
they state are their principles and as
soon as those principles would would go
counter to what they want as the
preconceived predetermined outcome then
they abandon the principle so that's
check and then number two
reactionaries vastly inflate the threat
of whatever they oppose
they you know we might just be against
something for some kind of you know
sensible reason
and we just don't like it but nothing
catastrophic is going to happen but no
they have to inflate the threat and say
it will be a catastrophe if x happens
and what that does is it drives
disproportionate responses if you're
told oh yeah i mean you know if schools
require a coveted vaccine next thing you
know we'll all be in cages
that drives a disproportionate response
when it's like actually there have been
vaccine requirements for a hundred years
and it doesn't escalate there's no
slippery slope and and we'll talk about
that next and there's a lot of uh we've
seen a lot of that in history like the
anti-communist movement of the 20th
century remember i'm not a socialist i'm
not a communist but i accurately see
that there was no threat right when we
go to the mccarthy hearings etc um
it's threat inflation this is going to
end everything it's going to end life as
we know it and uh really a master class
in fascistic authoritarian
fear-mongering here from glenn beck and
james lindsey and we've got a similar
thing in the next segment when it comes
to dave rubin so let's talk about that
next
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcast 2
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded
try blink is for free and get 25 off a
subscription go to blinkist.com
pacman the link is down below